people think walls separate us
but they also protect us it's gonna be
hot getting a little warm you should
learn to those people out there kept us
in a cage for 200 years that is not
someone I want to engage with
nothing to worry about you're safe now
welcome your arrival is the most
exciting event some of us have ever
known
hey for elevating who we are our
surveillance technology is centuries
ahead of anything you've known they've
grown up watching nothing creepy about
that so buy is eaten you've been
assigned to me it's a lot of firepower
that'll take you a while to get the hang
of it
I think I got the hang of it in 200
years the greatest scientific minds have
lived here to test a theory if we could
rescue people from the toxic environment
and put them in a safe place like
Chicago perhaps they would heal it and
I'm one of those people you're the only
one so worth sustaining this population
that's determined to destroy themselves
they're shutting us down Chicago will be
erased everyone we know will die you
were right all along
we have to leave right now why are you
going against us us against the people
on the other side of that wall
they're trying to destroy us where you
going
we're saving the city shooter down
you